i like your movies more okay oh come on
man don't make me flash up here
i mean some of our favorites was the uh
the big short wait that wait what
no no no it's not my hip-hop hobbit
that's good wait that's not that's not
my movie
movie you did that what the [ __ ] are you
talking about i never did that
when you think of the greatest comedians
of all time even stand-up comedians you
have
eddie chris
yes i didn't expect
robin
and then that's it really that's it when
you think of comedic rock stars that's
kind of it you guys aren't bringing it
over y'all weren't burning it back
let me set that
he's not gonna be able to believe that
i'm here watch this watch
he's gonna be so pumped up that i'm here
tonight man wait
wait until he picks up i know he's gonna
be pumped up about it hold on
wait a second hold on one sec let me try
let me just try him maybe he's driving
or something no he's not driving he's
got a chauffeur that guy's
he's got a lot of people to drive for
him he's just he probably didn't see it
give him two minutes he'll pick up snore
that makes it worse though big time
snore
still coming out now okay well you fart
in your sleep how about that well that's
a different situation he
farts in his sleep gas x it's uh not my
best friend
whatever he sleeps with a diaper he's a
person all right these are personal
problems
that nobody needs to know i'm gonna try
him again watch this
he's gonna he's gonna go crazy watch
this
as soon as he picks up in like two
seconds he's going to go he's going to
go
crazy the fact that i'm here that you're
here
he can edit all the time we can edit all
this out you don't have to edit it
give me a second big fan of all of his
movies well yeah i loved all of his
movies that's the thing i mean home
alone and no yeah
i love that one those are beverly hills
cops
what are you talking about that's not my
movie oh you know what i don't know
okay what's great this is that's chris
rob man you just name another black
community
you're not even you're not even trying
that is great now that's that's honestly
crazy because normally he picks up
like two seconds huh what i have his
number
you know dwayne like that you you gotta
well he's not gonna pick up he's busy so
this isn't
you could try but i doubt that he picked
up the phone
he would have picked up for me i'll text
him
i'm a texan if there was a jumanji
league of superheroes
and dwayne you were black adam karen was
nebula and
jack was nacho libre who would kevin be
pete
he'd be honky pete what would his
superpowers be
i'd be black adam look at a honky pete
you know what's crazy yeah look about
kevin and i know you're shooting the
show and the audience will
love this too because they probably feel
the same way kevin to me is like
he's like a little gremlin that
i just i just want to take him and throw
him into oncoming
camera traffic up
you know how sometimes when people get
under your skin and you just hate them
i'm not saying that what are you saying
it's you i'm just saying there's some
times where you just
really hate somebody sometimes you have
that personality when you walk in and
you're like you think everyone's like
hey
there's kevin great but you know all
right out here central time
my man kevin i'm going to do my part
yeah i know i'm going to do my part
we're seeing our cars right now hard
cars don't give me a sec well [ __ ]
how am i how are we here in london
this is my town and there is no you see
it aha
oh hold on a second hold on a second
kevin hart
look yes the big one goes by
for the big man himself yes
the king of the world [ __ ] your little
car
ah he's doing this i wish i was this
tall but i'll never get this time
no i'm always going to be shorter than
everybody's cat
[Music]
[Music]
getting tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ] you in
your video there you go hey don't
you know what my man hey whoever oh yeah
people can can bite that
okay five million people are gonna whip
the [ __ ] out of you
to [ __ ] off all right so basically you
better watch your [ __ ] mouth right
now how do you cuss so much [ __ ]
have some respect for the women here
sorry ladies and gentlemen you got a
foul
mouth okay my fans don't need to hear
that because we're better
than your people let me talk to you
you're right here's what your fans need
to hear amazing people
he loves the jungle here we are
intelligence
they shut us down the fire trucks are
out here will you get the [ __ ] out of my
video
what are you doing i'm trying to do my
best this is my video you're in my
[ __ ] video
watch your mouth [ __ ] you i'm kevin hart
right right in high school
okay um yeah hey hey hey hey
everybody hey hey girl
hey girl hey no she ain't hear me
hey what's up money no
he ain't seen me come on
[Music]
come on hey miss johnson yeah
i'm gonna do good on that test
yes i like your bad breath okay that's
good
i do not like it because you have you
dress clean fresh everything is cool and
when you talk it's like
yeah all right here we go wait we should
thank the people that's too late
right hey real quick before we start
this record-breaking
uh internet stream event
we didn't give it a title it's it's it's
it's a record-breaking
yeah internet stream yes historic event
moment yes
historic event moment with the rock
and kevin no we're kevin hart
in the pebble no no oh don't laugh at
that
dwayne johnson it is
kevin the hitman heart
and the bald guy
yes yes it is the rock up in this [ __ ]
and chocolate
hey if you if you just tuned into this
live stream
we got kevin mother [ __ ] heart
in him that's true that's true
and for the world who's tuning in
because this is going to be the biggest
live stream ever
we got the rock in the [ __ ]
house
we got kevin long faced little butt lou
aka my shoes are red and
he's on fire because he walks real fast
and his shoulders are broad and he's got
good skin
and he's the people person
and we got the [ __ ]